[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's drew brees who joined us on
joins us on the program good morning
drew how are you
dan i'm good man how are you i'm good
you're an analyst now
yeah i i guess that's the first time
i've
i've been introduced that way so i just
got to let that sink in for a second
but former quarterback that's weird
um i i don't i i actually think the uh
i think the transition is pretty natural
you know um
i think that uh you know you play you
play long enough which
man i had the chance to play 20 years
right quarterback in the national
football league
never my wildest dreams that i think i'd
i'd have that opportunity certainly the
opportunity to play that long
but um you know you basically go from
the way that you prepare for a game and
then actually go out and execute that
plan
as a quarterback and you now transition
into a position where
you're basically doing the same thing
but you're just
instead of actually doing it you're just
you're talking about it you're
describing it
you're still in you're still studying
film the same way you're still
um uh anticipating what's going to
happen
you know based on uh what you're
watching and
i think at the end of the day this is a
really fun opportunity a great
opportunity
for me to just show my love and passion
for the game of football
in a different way and maybe a way that
connects with fans even more
from the perspective that me you know i
want to make it fun i want to make it
educational um and exciting
all right let me uh let me give you your
first question as an analyst
who should be the starter at quarterback
for the saints
you know what uh it'll be interesting um
i think
however that you know competition um
is kind of laid out or or plays out
i think both those guys you know have
some unique skill sets
um i'd say obviously jamis and taysom
are
different styles of quarterback um and
whatever offense is run i think you you
know just like you would do for any
quarterback you
you make the adjustments within the
framework of the offense to fit the
skill set that you're dealing with you
know
see i would never let you get by if i
was on football night in america with
that answer
well i've got i really like both those
guys i think they both have the ability
to be
really good nfl quarterbacks and so then
it's just a matter of
hey they just happen to be in the same
place right now you know um
so we'll see how it plays out but taysom
has proven he can win games
um i think jameis you know leaving tampa
coming to us spending a year in our
system
i think he's developed a new level of
confidence
and ability to run our system so it'll
be interesting to see
did you realize the impact you had on
jameis because he got really emotional
when he was asked about
you know being there in new orleans with
you
yeah you know that was uh man that was
humbling um
we had a great qb room man we had a lot
of fun together um
i i always took it as a great
responsibility
to help um help young guys help
help the guys that were in our room i
know that some guys maybe take a
different approach
you know maybe they look at it as this
is the guy who's coming in trying to
take my job and so i'm not
i'm not going to extend any help or
advice or guidance
i i took a very different approach
because i knew how many veteran
quarterbacks
as i was coming up helped me and
mentored me
and i can't tell you how much
confidence that gave me and really how
that helped guide me through
through my early years you know when i
when i had some struggles
and so i've always kind of made it a
commitment that if any young quarterback
reached out to me
or was in my room with the saints man i
was
i was going to do everything i could to
help them be the best that they could be
and
i did i tried to do that for jameis
yeah your first game you came in and
replaced doug flutie i believe right
yep who was that drew brees back then
how different
is he than this drew brees now
oh man light years you know i you know
what's amazing to me now i mean i've
watched our offense
evolve right with the new orleans saints
from 2006 until now you know so 15 years
of evolution
i mean it is it is the complexities
of what we are doing now are light years
different
than back then my first year um
with the in the saints offense like i
went back and looked at
a call sheet from our very first game
against the cleveland browns in 2006.
give me give me a for instance
give me an example here of what the call
would have been back then
well so so for example
like the most basic formation the most
basic protection
the most basic play concept gun
red right 24 scan
y flutie and by the way that why flutie
that's a concept that everybody in the
nfl runs but when i was with the
chargers
it was one of doug flutie's favorite
place so we nicknamed it flutie
because we were starting to transition
to some no huddle stuff and we needed
code words
so we code worded a concept fluty
and we were the first ones to do that
because doug flutie was on our team
well then you have coaches that end up
going to different places you know
from there and taking that terminology
so
i'd be willing to bet there's probably
about six to eight teams in the league
that actually
run flutie and call it fluty
so it's funny how those things just kind
of spread give me the most complicated
call you
ever had well
so it'd be like uh all right so boogie
to green left slot let's go x short
tight pass 37 buster nudge
uh why footy sting uh
z spear kill 53 titan left
so like the the the terminology can be
endless
you know and and here's the worst part
is that so that's that play call
and now you're in a loud stadium and
let's say the headset cuts off after the
coach says look at the green lifestyle
right like you don't realize how often
that stuff happens
you know and or then play cox going down
and you just have to
i mean you are like thinking on the fly
you're having to just pick up
you know bits and pieces and put it all
together and oh by the way
maybe it's a different personnel group
in the huddle you know that was a
such a specific thing and somebody you
know tweaked an ankle and now they're on
the sideline another guy's daddy you're
getting him coached up on what his split
is it's a minus two split it's not an
outside edge split
man there's so much stuff is happening
and so fast
that man it's it's kind of a
free-for-all at times but
man that's that's what you love about
the game it's what makes it fun and
exciting never a dull moment
what'd you keep from your last game
what's my what what did you keep from
your last game
what did i keep yeah uniform everything
play sheets the memories the memories of
my kids on the field after the game
probably was the most significant part
of that
um so nothing nothing
um tangible you know from like a jersey
or cleats or anything like that it was
i mean listen you don't it's not like
you just wake up one day and say oh i
think i'm going to retire today you know
i mean that's that's a that's a process
you know it's a couple year process that
you you begin thinking about how
how that's going to happen and you knew
before that game started if you lose to
the buccaneers that that's your last
game
well i know it was my last home game you
know because we were going to go on the
road and play
in the playoffs and hope you know the
packers and hopefully on to the super
bowl but
um so i knew it was my last home game
you know there was there was
significance with that anyway
you didn't want to you didn't want to
leave the field though with brady did it
help in any way that you
if you're going to lose a game you lose
to brady or is that the last person you
want to lose to
well i didn't i didn't want to lose
period you know i mean considering that
you're playing against
a guy like him who i have a great
relationship with and you know we go way
back you know we played against each
other in college
right and so we've kind of been on this
journey you know
uh together in a lot of ways
you know we kind of share one of the
same mentors
um so i mean just a ton of respect
you know i know i think i think
any any quarterback in the in the nfl
only only those guys can can really
understand
um what it takes to play that position
and and all the
the preparation and the
this uh just the time and the attention
to detail in the headspace that that
that takes up
um you know during the course of a
season
but yeah i mean it's
i've had the chance to play against them
a lot of times three times this year
you know so that's we've got a
great relationship and obviously we know
what kind of a player he is
drew joins us on behalf of copper
compression the number one best seller
on amazon in the uh personal care
category
are you going to be in the backyard
throwing footballs with uh
fellow hall of famers here soon
[Laughter]
yeah i uh are you on the other team
because favre gets jerry rice and i
never understood that
like that's not fair i was i was gonna
say this would be like the uh
you know the battle of the the battle of
the copper compression products
you know but uh i i just i need to go
choose i need to go choose my receiver
he chose jerry rice that's a that's a
pretty good one um
i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna have
tryouts i'm i'm gonna conduct
the copper compression tryouts i'm gonna
i'm gonna pull
i'm gonna pull some guys you know pull
some guys out of their living rooms and
uh
have a combine a combine that's what i'm
saying
it's going to be like a mini combine i i
gotta choose my wide receiver
um from from history to take on brett
favre
and uh and jerry rice and then and then
and then the random guys that are you
know just in the park
yeah um you know tom from ups is out
there
i i feel bad for him tom from ups is out
there trying to cover jerry rice i mean
it's just not fair
yeah yeah i mean listen you just take
away the inside
that's that's what i would do just take
away the slant and
then have somebody play over the top uh
can you how many broken ribs did you
have and they are they all healed now
yeah i i believe they're all healed i
had i had 11. i had eight on the left
side three on the right
um but i i didn't even know you had that
many ribs i didn't either
i didn't i didn't know either yeah yeah
it was
it was that was it was a crazy deal i
obviously never
never felt anything like that and yet at
the same time it wasn't
um i mean it sounds crazy
your your mindset is such that man
nothing's going to take you off the
field
you know so so you don't even you don't
even recognize the severity of anything
because you're just you're pushing
through you're pushing through and
the the eight that i fractured on the
left side were in the tampa the first
tampa game and not the first champion
the second tampa game was the sunday
night game at tampa
second quarter i i i kind of get slammed
to the ground on the left side
and i knew something was wrong i mean it
was a feeling i hadn't had
you know the wind gets knocked out of
you that happens a lot but
all of a sudden i felt like man i'm
having trouble breathing i can't rotate
but i had a hard time throwing the ball
in the second half of that game i mean
it was
functional we got the job done but um
you know we win that game big and but i
know something's wrong i wake up the
next day go to the mri got all these
broken ribs and it's like all right well
let's just find a way to get to sunday i
mean that's that's really the saying
amongst all nfl players
you know find find a way to get to the
next game you know
and so man training room rehab i i
didn't practice much that week i i just
tried to get ready to practice on friday
that week just to
and i was in i was in so much pain on
friday and so i was like
i don't know how i'm going to do this so
got out on sunday and
you know felt actually decent going into
that next game which was against the
niners
and then sure enough in the second
quarter of that game i get thrown down
on the other side and that's what
fractured the three ribs and then
punctured along
and that was so it's one thing to have
have to have all that
going on on one side of your body but
then to have it on both sides
the problem at that point was as that
game progressed i mean i finished the
half
and we we took the lead i felt like we
had the game in hand
but when you sit at halftime for 25
minutes and then come back out
and i couldn't rotate i couldn't do
anything so i basically went to shawn
and like man i can throw the ball like
15 yards right now that's about it so
you know i think in my mind too i was
thinking all right i know this is going
to put me out for a period of time
i could go out there and make this thing
worse or i could just shut it down let's
win this game
which i felt like we would anyway and
then try to make it back as quick as i
could
well you don't have to worry about that
now i i don't think if you get any kind
of
rib damage it'll be just from your kids
hugging hugging you
right the only ribs will be on the
traeger grill
that's exactly right those are the only
ribs i'm worried about right now
and how i'm seasoning those babies
before i smoke them hey uh
congrats good luck with uh copper
compression uh
the number one best seller on amazon in
the personal care category play nice
with
brett favre and company and then uh good
luck on football night in america
that's right copper compression is gonna
help keep me young i can swing it around
in the yard of these
these these uh future hall of famers i
got running around this house
and your kids yeah oh that's what you
mean yeah future hall of fame
yeah yeah um hey did you pick up did you
pick up on that one
yes i did yeah i did it took me a little
while took me a little while
that's why i only play i played
quarterback as a freshman in high school
that was as far as i got
[Laughter]
i love it all right man i hope to see
you soon thank you bud that's drew brees